[Musica]
[Applauso]
abbiamo parlato di luoghi e oggi vi
voglio parlare brevemente del museo
egizio ma a dire il vero vi voglio
parlare di come un progetto un sogno si
possa realizzare se a dare le gambe a
questo progetto ci sono delle persone
il museo egizio ha appena vissuto un
momento incredibile la un sogno che è
diventato realtà la possibilità di
trasformare completamente l'edificio in
cui esso è ospitato in un nuovo museo
moderno che a 10 mila metri quadri due
chilometri e mezzo di percorso
espositivo e questo non sarebbe mai
stato possibile se non ci fosse stata
una squadra dietro che con abnegazione
con volontà ha lavorato giorno dopo
giorno tenendo il museo aperto e
trasportando questi reperti che vedete
di un valore incredibile e di un'età
media di 2500 anni vedete il momento in
cui la tomba di kha il nostro tesoro più
importante la tomba del dell'architetto
del faraone viene smontata i reperti
vengono messi in sicurezza e vengono
trasportati nelle nuove sale mentre il
museo rimane aperto mentre anche in
quell anno siamo riusciti a fare 567
mila visitatori
ma lavorare con questi oggetti è la
passione che ci ha spinti a creare a
realizzare questo sogno che sembrava
impossibile quando la lotta contro il
tempo diveniva sempre più stringente
quando come in questo momento abbiamo
dovuto tirare giù il libro dei morti
dica 14 metri 50 del libro dei morti
arrotolarlo e poi sono tolar lo stando
attenti che ogni singola fibra rimanesse
intatta e che questo reperto unico al
mondo non venisse danneggiato in alcun
modo è quello è stato un momento magico
forse irripetibile ma la cosa che
ricordo di quei momenti è la ricerca e
la voglia di conoscere questa collezione
di capirla
e di farla vivere ed un certo momento
avevamo un esercito di restauratori che
qui vedete che con pazienza cercavano di
reidratare reperti di metterli in
sicurezza di studiare le mummie di farla
diagnostica di capire in che modo questi
oggetti potessero essere mossi per
arrivare nel loro nuovo sede per poter
poi essere fruiti dai visitatori e in
quel momento il museo egizio era
trasformato non era più un deposito di
reperti un sé una semplice collezione ma
stava diventando un luogo di ricerca e
grazie al lavoro di tutti vedete alcune
salerno ancora né dei cantieri nelle
altre stavamo già mostrando le opere e
poi avevamo un esercito di operai di
signore delle pulizie che giorno e notte
pulivano per far depositare la polvere
di modo che poi noi di giorno potessimo
mettere i reperti nelle vetrine e così
giorno dopo giorno ora dopo ora il museo
prendeva forma le sale e cominciavano ad
essere decorate le vetrine cominciavano
a contenere i reperti tutto veniva
documentato e filmato perché anche
questa è storia irripetibile che deve
rimanere e si arrivava così al primo
aprile 2015 ad aprire museo egizio però
questo mi fece subito riflettere quel
primo aprile non doveva essere un punto
di parte un punto di arrivo ma un punto
di partenza
beh forse un punto di arrivo di una
lunga storia che polizià inizia a
quattrocento anni fa quando a torino
arriva alla mense si sa che nel 1626 e
quando si capisce che questa città indo
lussu bilmente sarà legata all'egitto e
pochi anni dopo nel 1759 i savoia
mandano vitaliano donati un professore
di botanica della regia università per
andare in egitto per scopo per trovare
dei reperti che possano spiegare la
mensa isiaca è forse il momento più
importante il momento magico per questo
posto fu nel 1819 quando quel signore
che vedete la vostra destra carlo vidua
scrisse una lettera al sovrano e disse
che torino doveva comprare la collezione
raccolta da drovetti e solo se l'avesse
fatto ma lo scrisse nel 19 42 anni prima
dell'unità d'italia e benedisse l'italia
diventerà un grande paese perché avrà la
prima collezione di antichità classiche
roma la prima collezione di antichità
rinascimentali in firenze e la prima
collezione egizia in torino e quel sogno
si realizzò nel 1824 la collezione
arrivo e come vedete il museo era un
luogo di studi un luogo in cui cultura
materiale e libri erano presenti per
capire il passato di questa civiltà ma
anche per rispondere alle domande
fondamentali dell'uomo
e i primi papiri vengono studiati e si
capì che esisteva un arte egizia in un
momento in cui l'arte egizia veniva
considerata subalterna forse prodromica
solo a quella greca e questa nostra
magnifica città divenne un centro vitale
per l'egittologia ed accolse jean
françois champollion e di decifratore
dei geroglifici che arrivò subito a
torino per studiare i reperti per
catalogarli per capirli e disse che la
via per menfi e tebe passava per torino
che torino era il centro di una nuova
storia che si stava scrivendo la storia
dell'egittologia che era appena nata e
questo percorso venneri saldato nel 1894
quando arrivò la direzione del museo
egizio ernesto schiapparelli che capì
che per mantenere quel primato torino
doveva diventare un grande centro di
ricerca un grande centro di studi e così
il 15 febbraio del 1906 lui si trovò ad
enel medina e gli operai trovarono in
questo villaggio un'apertura un pozzo
che scendeva per otto metri 50 e noi
stiamo rientrando con lui in quel
momento grazie alle sue foto ei suoi
disegni trovarono una prima sala gradoni
che era coperta poi una seconda sala
anche questa bloccata e una volta tolte
le pietre si trovarono di fronte a
quella porta ancora sigillata e
schiapparelli capi che per la prima
volta si stava rientrando in una camera
sepolcrale che era stata chiusa per
tremila anni e noi entriamo con lui in
quel momento e ritroviamo questi 550
reperti i sarcofagi le suppellettili il
cibo tutto quello che era stato
conservato in questa sala e che adesso è
al museo egizio perché il museo egizio
contiene
l'unica tomba del nuovo regno intatta
che si sia preservata e che sia oggi
fuori dall'egitto
questa è un'altra grande ricchezza che
non ci sarebbe se schiapparelli non
avesse capito che la ricerca e
l'archeologia era la nuova chiave ebbene
ho detto che la riapertura era un punto
di partenza non un punto d'arrivo e
allora oggi ci dobbiamo interrogare su
quale possa essere il futuro del museo
egizio per forse l'articolo 9 della
costituzione ci dà la risposta perché
dice che la repubblica la res pubblica
quindi tutti noi dobbiamo promuovere lo
sviluppo della cultura e la ricerca
scientifica e tecnica dalla conoscenza e
dalla cultura per viene poi anche la
tutela la conservazione dei beni che
abbiamo ricevuto in dono dai nostri
padri
e allora il museo egizio deve tornare ad
essere un centro di ricerca e se il
primo aprile 2015 abbiamo riaperto il
primo maggio 2015 siamo tornati in
egitto siamo tornati a scavare saqqara
siamo tornati a scavare quelle tombe
dalle cui camere provengono i reperti
che conserviamo il museo egizio e questo
per noi è la conditio sine qua non per
poter poi trasmettere quello che
sappiamo per fare percorsi di
apprendimento per tutti i giovani adulti
per accogliere nell'alternanza scuola e
lavoro i ragazzi che vengono da noi per
fare un percorso di formazione imparino
a conoscere questa collezione
ma forse il sogno più bello è quello di
radicare il museo nella sua società e
portare il museo fuori dal museo è una
cosa a cui tengo molto e che sta dando
tantissimo noi c'è chi al museo non può
venire come i bambini malati del regina
margherita ea quel punto siamo noi a
portare il museo da loro come siamo noi
a portare museo delle carceri come siamo
noi che vogliamo adesso portare il museo
nelle case di riposo perché il museo
appartiene a tutti
a chi può venire che non può venire e
quando dico che appartiene a tutti
appartiene alla società una società
continuamente cangiante alla società che
la fortuna adesso in torino di
accogliere circa 34.000 persone che
provengono dal nord africa e che in
questa collezione possono riconoscere le
radici del loro futuro si possono
sentire il benvenuti in questo nuovo
torino e capire che grazie
un grandissimo paese del nord africa
questa città la fortuna ha l'onore e
l'onere di conservare una cultura
materiale che appartiene a loro al loro
paese di provenienza e loro possono
diventare ambasciatori di questa
collezione
e allora proprio per questo siamo
partiti con una campagna in cui noi
crediamo molto e che intitoliamo
fortunato chi parla arabo
fortunato chi parla arabo perché in
questa città in questo museo può trovare
la sua casa perché in questa città può
entrare in dialogo con noi
e allora se la nuova identità del museo
deve essere quella di un centro di
ricerca perché senza la ricerca non
abbiamo contenuti da trasmettere senza
la ricerca non abbiamo nuovi contenuti
da trasmettere da far percepire al
nostro pubblico è bene il museo
se questo farà diventerà anche un luogo
di cultura un luogo in cui si potranno
ricreare questi ponti fra la nostra
sponda del mediterraneo e la sponda sud
del mediterraneo consapevoli che senza
l'egitto noi questo musei non avremmo
mai avuto
e allora il museo sarà un'entità viva e
dinamica
forse solo in quel momento potremmo dire
this must be the place perché luogo
strafatto di persone che quotidianamente
fanno ricerca che la sanno mettere a
frutto della società civile in cui
stanno sono inseriti consapevoli che
nessuna istituzione culturale come
diceva il direttore del metropolitan
museum of art può avere l'arroganza di
pensare di esistere per il diritto
divino ma la sua esistenza
se la deve conquistare giorno per giorno
in un dialogo costante con il suo
pubblico andandolo a conquistare e
confrontandosi quotidianamente
[Musica]
grazie
[Applauso]